hello how are you, greets héctor mejía
this is your informative brief for today
thursday first of april there is another
project in transition to connect
southern nevada with southern california
this time the road would be by train the
hamster plans show that the
service would add  a route between las
vegas and los angeles is one of many
proposals but it all depends on
federal funds
to other news returns to the
first
friday festival in person tomorrow night at
the art of tea establishment although
still located a  almost a mile from the
container because the bad news is that
there is no more space available this party
has been promoted online since
April of last year but now
it will finally be done in person
and today reiter sharing real will open inside
the work the motto is everything  about the
raiders now the las vegas team
this venue is expected to be the choice
of many fans during
the nfl season this  It will be running daily and it
is the only official
team restaurant in the entire world
and now we turn to the
weather forecast we will have another hot sunny day
close to 80 degrees
however these temperatures will continue to
rise as we will hit the 90s
by the end of  Have a nice
day this week I am Héctor Mejía and this was your
brief briefing in Spanish
[Music]